>> HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
LAST WEEK.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> IT'S MOROCCO.
>> HI, GIRLS.
I'M HERE FOR GO-SEES.
>> GO!
>> (tires screech)
>> THIS IS BULL... (bleep).
>> MOLLY NEEDS TO BE ABLE
TO BE FRIENDLIER ON CAMERA.
>> UGH!
>> IT SMELLS
JUST A LITTLE BIT RIPE.
>> RELAX THE FACE.
>> UGH! THIS IS UNSANITARY.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING
AFTER ALL OF THE DRAMA
FROM LAST WEEK?
>> I REALLY WANTED TO APOLOGIZE.
>> JACLYN, YOU ONLY MADE IT
TO TWO GO-SEES.
AND JACLYN WAS SENT HOME.
FIVE GIRLS LEFT--
MOLLY, HANNAH,
BRITTANI, KASIA,
AND ALEXANDRIA--
BUT ONLY ONE WILL HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH IMG, COVERGIRL,
AND APPEAR ON THE PAGES
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
(Moroccan music playing)
>> ♪ OH ♪
(tires screech)
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> OH, MY GOD.
OH, I'M SO EXCITED.
>> YAY! I'M GOING TO MOROCCO!
TOP FIVE!
>> MOROCCO!
>> WHAT? LIKE, I CAME
FROM THE TRAILER PARK
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE IS
JUST INCREDIBLE RIGHT NOW.
I'M TOTALLY JUST...
I'M GOING TO KICK SOME ASS NOW.
>> I CANNOT BELIEVE
WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
I FEEL VERY POSITIVE.
IN OUR LAST ELIMINATION,
I RECEIVED BEST PICTURE.
>> THIS IS TRUE HIGH FASHION.
>> (giggles)
AND I FEEL LIKE I'M GETTING
A LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF THE PACK.
IT WAS A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR ME
IN THE BEGINNING.
YOU KNOW I FELT LIKE
I WAS REALLY MISUNDERSTOOD,
AND THAT PEOPLE HAD
THIS BAD, NEGATIVE IMAGE
ABOUT ME.
>> HEY, ALEXANDRIA, YOU'RE FAKE.
>> THAT'S NOT NICE.
WHAT THEY DON'T KNOW IS
I CAN CHANGE.
I'M LIKE A CHAMELEON.
OKAY, I HAVE A GECKO AT HOME.
HE DOESN'T CHANGE COLORS,
BUT I SURE DO.
(ding)
>> IS THAT A CAMEL?
>> OH, MY GOD! IT'S REAL!
WHOO! CAMELS!
>> STOP TALKING IN MY EAR.
>> I'M SORRY, BUT IT'S A CAMEL.
HOW COULD YOU NOT BE EXCITED?
>> I WAS PISSED.
I DIDN'T THINK I DESERVED
TO BE IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
APPARENTLY, I LOOK LIKE
I WANNA KILL EVERYONE.
>> THE GENERAL NOTE WAS
ALL THE GO-SEES
LOVED YOUR PORTFOLIO,
BUT YOU COME ACROSS COLD
AND NOT PRESENT.
THAT WAS THE PROBLEM.
IT'S ABOUT FAKING IT
WHEN YOU FEEL LIKE CRAP.
>> I THINK I HAVE
A COUPLE OF PLACES
WHERE THE ANGER COMES FROM.
I HAD A LOT OF SADNESS
AND A LOT OF HURT.
YOU KNOW, I THINK BEING ADOPTED
GAVE ME SOME ISSUES,
YOU KNOW, ABANDONMENT ISSUES.
SO, YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHY
I'M MAD ALL THE TIME.
OBVIOUSLY, I HAVE TO ACT
LIKE A TOTALLY DIFFERENT PERSON
AND BE FAKE.
I THINK IT'S (bleep),
BUT THAT'S WHAT I HAVE TO DO.
I HAVE TO ACT MORE
LIKE ALEXANDRIA.
>> (gasps)
I WANNA DO A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH A CAMEL!
>> IT'S GOT CAMEL TOES.
>> (laughs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M GETTING CHILLS RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S SO COOL.
>> WELCOME TO MARRAKECH.
>> WE ARRIVE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE BIG MARKETPLACE,
WHERE THERE'S
TONS OF PEOPLE AROUND.
THERE'S MONKEYS AND COBRAS,
THE GUY WITH THE COBRA THING.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M THE OLDEST.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
THE LONGEST, BUT, LIKE,
THE FACT THAT I EVEN HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY IS
UNBELIEVABLE,
AND I'M GONNA WORK
SO MUCH HARDER
THAN ANYBODY ELSE
BECAUSE I THINK I HAVE TO
AS A PLUS SIZE MODEL.
BECAUSE NO, I WOULDN'T NORMALLY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WALK INTO IMG.
THEY DON'T HAVE A PLUS DIVISION,
BUT THEY HAVE SUPERSTARS,
AND I'M HOPING THAT'S
WHERE I'M GONNA BE, YOU KNOW.
THEY'RE GONNA MAKE ROOM FOR ME.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M LOOKING AT THESE SNAKES,
AND I'M LIKE,
NO.
AAH!
WHERE I'M FROM,
IT'S REALLY COUNTRY,
REALLY HICK.
YOU SEE A SNAKE, YOU KILL IT,
YOU SKIN IT, YOU EAT IT.
AND AT THE BAR I WORK AT,
WE THEN HANG THE SKIN
ON THE WALL.
>> OHH!
>> THE J's SHOW UP,
AND I'M JUST LIKE, OH!
LIKE, AREN'T YOU GUYS CUTE
TODAY?
>> WELCOME TO MARRAKECH.
YOU ARE STANDING IN FRONT
OF THE FAMOUS DJEMAA EL-FNA,
THE MAIN MARKETPLACE
IN MARRAKECH.
>> BY THE WAY, YOU LOOK LOVELY.
>> THANK YOU.
I LOOK ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
>> (chuckles)
DESIGNERS HAVE BEEN INSPIRED
BY MOROCCO,
AND MAJOR MODELS LIKE KATE MOSS
FREQUENT HERE FOR PHOTO SHOOTS,
AND SHE LOVES TO SHOP.
AND YVES SAINT LAURENT
CONSIDERED MARRAKECH
HIS SECOND HOME.
ONE OF YOU IS GONNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND IT'S TIME FOR YOU
TO BE INSPIRED BY
THE AMAZING CULTURE
THAT IS MARRAKECH, MOROCCO.
YOU GUYS HAVE AN AMAZING DAY
AHEAD OF YOU.
WE ARRANGED FOR
A TRADITIONAL MOROCCAN LUNCH
AND A FASHION TOUR OF MARRAKECH.
ALL THE SIGHTS THAT A TOP MODEL
SHOULD SEE.
YOU GUYS CAN COME UP
AND LOOK AT THE SNAKES
IF YOU WANT.
>> I'M SCARED.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> WHAT IS THIS?
OH, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
I DID NOT KNOW
A MONKEY WAS ON ME.
I CAN'T BREATHE.
HE WAS JUMPING
ALL OVER MY SCARF,
AND I WAS LIKE, I'M GONNA
WEAR THIS, LIKE, EVERY DAY.
PLEASE DON'T GIVE ME, LIKE,
RINGWORM OR I DIDN'T KNOW.
>> SO LET'S GET YOU
IN A LITTLE BIT OF A POSE.
ONE, TWO, THREE. HIT IT.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> SO YOU GUYS ARE HUNGRY,
RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA GO FOR LUNCH,
AND THEN REALLY ENJOY THE DAY.
DRINK IT IN,
SO IT ALL GOES IN HERE,
SO YOU HAVE SOMETHING
ON THAT NEXT PHOTO SHOOT
IN HERE AS INSPIRATION.
SEE YOU GUYS.
>> BYE.
>> THANK YOU.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> NO!
>> I FEEL LIKE ALADDIN.
>> (gasps) OOH!
DUDE!
>> THE PRIZE PACKAGE
FOR "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
IS INSANE.
$100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS
AND "VOGUE ITALIA."
WHOA! WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> POTPOURRI FLOWER.
>> IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE COMPETITION,
I KIND OF FELL THROUGH
THE CRACKS A LITTLE BIT
AS FAR AS NOT BEING MEMORABLE.
>> HANNAH, IT WAS INTERESTING,
BUT IT WASN'T THAT MEMORABLE
FOR ME.
>> I HAVE TO JUST REMEMBER
WHERE I COME FROM.
I'M AN ONLY CHILD,
AND MY PARENTS TAUGHT ME
WHAT I HAVE TO WORK WITH
IS ENOUGH,
AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR ME
TO ACTUALLY BELIEVE IN MYSELF.
I'M GONNA PUT THE OTHER GIRLS
IN THE SHADOWS.
>> SO WE'RE PRETTY MUCH
JUST WANDERING AROUND MARRAKECH,
GETTING A FEEL FOR THE CULTURE,
THEN WE GET LED INTO
THIS BEAUTIFUL RESTAURANT.
>> MMM!
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
>> CHEERS.
>> MOROCCO!
>> MMM! IT'S, LIKE,
EVERY SINGLE THING
I PUT IN MY MOUTH IS FANTASTIC.
>> YEAH.
>> MMM!
>> IT'S, LIKE, REALLY
KIND OF UNBELIEVABLE TO BE HERE.
I HAD THIS FEELING
THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T SEE ME
AS COMPETITION
JUST BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT I'M THE PLUS SIZE MODEL
IN THE HOUSE.
BUT BEAUTY COMES IN, YOU KNOW,
MORE FORMS THAN, LIKE,
A SIZE 2 MODEL.
I MEAN, I'M SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
>> WE'RE THE LUCKIEST--
>> WE'RE THE LUCKIEST GIRLS
IN THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
>> START TRYING FOOD
I'VE NEVER HAD.
>> I DEFINITELY THINK
I'M STRONGER THAN KASIA
AS FAR AS HIGH FASHION MODELING
GOES.
I MEAN, I KNOW SHE WANTS
TO CHANGE THE INDUSTRY,
BUT I FEEL LIKE
I HAVE STRONGER PICTURES.
I HAVE A STRONGER WALK.
>> THERE'S MORE.
>> SHUT UP.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> OH, MY GOSH!
>> I DEFINITELY HAVEN'T
FELT SAFE THE PAST TWO JUDGINGS
BECAUSE OF
THE WHOLE ALEXANDRIA THING.
WE ALL GAVE YOU A CHANCE.
>> I DON'T CARE.
>> IF YOU DON'T CARE,
THEN HOW ABOUT
YOU JUST STOP TALKING?
>> THIS IS A BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE TO RESPECT THE CLIENT,
YOU HAVE TO RESPECT
YOUR COWORKERS,
AND YOU HAVE TO RESPECT
YOURSELF.
I FELT REALLY BAD THAT THAT'S
HOW TYRA PERCEIVES ME NOW,
BUT NOW THAT ME AND ALEXANDRIA
ARE COOL
AND I APOLOGIZED TO TYRA,
IT WAS JUST LIKE A WEIGHT
WAS LIFTED OFF MY SHOULDERS.
I LOVE THIS PLACE.
LIKE, THIS IS THE STYLE
OF MY HOUSE...
>> REALLY?
>> IN THE FUTURE.
>> OH.
>> YOU KEEP--KEEP FORGETTING
I LIVE IN A TRAILER.
COMING FROM
A LESS FORTUNATE FAMILY,
MODELING IS A REALLY RISKY THING
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS
TO JUST TAKE OFF TO NEW YORK
AND BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR AN APARTMENT
AND REALLY TRY TO GET OUT THERE.
AND SO THIS OPPORTUNITY IS
KIND OF MY LAST HOPE,
AND I'M GONNA FIGHT
UNTIL I GET IT
BECAUSE I DO WANNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (groans)
(bell tolls)
(man speaks in Arabic)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> VILLA AMIR.
>> YEAH.
>> LET'S GO!
>> PFFT!
>> SO WE SHOW UP
AT WHAT LOOKS LIKE A VILLA.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> THIS IS SO COOL IN HERE.
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN,
WE SEE THIS FABULOUS SHOWROOM.
>> ♪ HEY! ♪
♪ HEY! ♪
>> I HOPE THESE ARE
YOUR TRAVEL CLOTHES.
I MEAN, YOU LOOK DREADFUL.
>> OH!
>> I SEE ANDRÉ, AND I'M LIKE,
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> YOU ARE
IN THE MAISONHAUTE COUTURE
DENOUREDDINE AMIR.
THIS IS A GREAT DESIGNER
FROM NORTH AFRICA.
HE FIRST STARTED OUT
AS AN ARTIST IN SCULPTURE,
AND FROM SCULPTURE,
HE MAKES EXTRAORDINARY,
BEAUTIFUL CLOTHES.
AND I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU ALL
TO TRY ON SOME THINGS
THAT NOUREDDINE AND I
HAVE SELECTED FOR YOU,
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
YOU WALK IN THEM.
>> OOH!
>> IT'S A BIG DEAL
TO WALK FOR ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY.
HE'S ONE OF OUR JUDGES,
OBVIOUSLY, BUT HE'S ALSO
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PEOPLE
IN FASHION.
IT'S A LOT OF PRESSURE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A GOOD IMPRESSION.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (squeals)
I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOD.
I JUST WANT TO
MODEL BESIDE IT.
I'M KIND OF TAKEN ABACK
BY THIS HIGH FASHION AND COUTURE
EXISTING IN MARRAKECH.
I KNEW I WAS REALLY GONNA
HAVE TO WALK PRETTY WELL
TO NOT LET THE DRESS KIND OF BE
THE CENTER OF ATTENTION
BECAUSE IT WAS
A REALLY BOLD PIECE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> BRITTANI IS
A VERY STRONG COMPETITOR
BECAUSE SHE'S PRETTY MUCH
JUST LIKE ME.
WE HAVE A NATURAL ABILITY
TO WALK VERY WELL,
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SOMETHING MORE,
AND I HAVE THAT.
>> THANK YOU, ANGEL. (laughs)
>> THANK YOU.
>> WILL THAT FIT ME?
>> YEAH.
>> YEAH?
WE EACH GET A DRESS,
BUT MINE DOESN'T FIT.
THE FIRST ONE DOESN'T FIT.
THE SECOND ONE DOESN'T FIT.
AM I TRYING SOMETHING ELSE?
THAT'S, LIKE, THE WORST FEELING.
I KNOW
A LOT OF EUROPEAN DESIGNERS
USE PLUS SIZE MODELS,
BUT MAYBE THEY'VE NEVER SEEN
A MODEL LIKE ME.
I DON'T KNOW.
HERE, I JUST GOT
THAT REALLY AWESOME FEELING
THAT THEY WERE JUST LIKE, "OKAY.
WHY THE (bleep) IS SHE HERE?"
THEY WENT THROUGH ABOUT
HALF THE STORE FOR ME.
HOPEFULLY THEY FIND
A SKIRT THAT FITS.
(voice breaks) LIKE,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO SAY.
IT SUCKS.
(woman speaks in Arabic)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THEY LITERALLY WENT THROUGH,
LIKE, THE WHOLE STORE, I THINK,
TO TRY TO FIT A DRESS ON ME,
WHICH IS KIND OF EMBARRASSING.
BUT I'M PUTTING MYSELF
OUT THERE TO BE SCRUTINIZED.
I KNOW THAT,
BUT THAT IT STILL HURTS.
IT CHIPS AWAY
AT MY CONFIDENCE A LITTLE.
AM I--AM I TRYING ANOTHER ONE?
>> YES.
OH, OKAY.
THE DRESS THAT THEY HAVE ME WEAR
IS IT'S REALLY HARD TO WALK IN.
IT'S REALLY HEAVY.
>> WELL, GREAT, MOLLY.
YOU'RE HOLDING YOUR DRESS,
AND I UNDERSTAND IT'S TOO LONG,
BUT YOU DID BEAUTIFULLY
GETTING TO THE END
OF THE RUNWAY.
THAT WAS GOOD. GO BACK AGAIN.
>> I DON'T DO THE BEST WALK
BECAUSE I HAVE
THIS RIDICULOUSLY LONG DRESS
THAT I CAN'T REALLY WALK IN.
>> STAND ON TIPPY TOES.
>> MOLLY--
SHE HAS A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
SHE COULD DEFINITELY
BE STRONGER THAN ME,
BUT SHE DOES GET ANGRY
AND COMPLAINS, AND I MEAN,
AROUND CLIENTS,
IT IS YOUR JOB TO KIND OF
PUT ON YOUR FAKE FACE
AND BE HAPPY,
JUST LIKE I HAVE TO
KEEP MY OPINIONS TO MYSELF
WHILE I'M AT WORK.
LIKE, WE'RE ALL LEARNING THINGS.
>> THANK YOU, DARLING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> NEXT.
I LIKE THE CONTROL OF YOUR WALK.
>> I'M JUST SUPER PSYCHED THAT
I'VE MADE IT TO THE TOP FIVE.
I MAY NOT HAVE, LIKE,
THE MOST EXPERIENCE HERE,
BUT I'M FRESH, I'M NEW,
I'M READY. BRING IT ON.
>> FINALLY THEY FIND
A SKIRT THAT FITS.
THE WHOLE TIME
I'M JUST HOLDING IT TOGETHER,
AND I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY REALLY NOTICED
OR MAYBE SAW THAT I WAS UPSET.
>> KASIA HAS ON HEELS?
>> WELL, I PACKED MINE.
>> THAT'S
A VERY IMPORTANT THING.
>> NONE OF THE GIRLS
BROUGHT THEIR HEELS
EXCEPT FOR ME.
THAT'S ONE OF, LIKE,
THE ABC's OF GOING OUT
AS A MODEL.
>> BUT YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
YOU'VE GOT CONTROL
OF THE BODY.
I LIKE THAT.
OH, ALEXANDRIA!
>> I STOOD ON MY TOES,
AND I WORKED THAT RUNWAY,
(record needle screeches)
>> NOW, ALEXANDRIA, GO BACK
AND TAKE THOSE SOCKS OFF.
TAKE THOSE SOCKS OFF, DARLING.
(laughs)
>> DUH!
(ding)
>> THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL DRESS
ON YOU.
YOU'VE GOT CONTROL OF YOUR WALK.
>> ALEXANDRIA'S
BEEN DOING REALLY WELL.
I DON'T GET WHY.
I NEVER THOUGHT I'D HAVE TO,
LIKE, REALLY WATCH OUT FOR HER,
BUT APPARENTLY, PEOPLE LIKE HER.
>> OKAY. THANK YOU, ALEXANDRIA.
I WOULD SAY
I NOTICED THAT YOU GIRLS
DID NOT HAVE HEELS
EXCEPT KASIA.
THAT WAS A GOOD CALL.
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO CARRY
A PAIR OF HEELS IN YOUR HANDBAG.
>> I HAVE A LOT MORE
LIFE EXPERIENCE
THAN THE YOUNGER GIRLS.
AND SOMETIMES I'M JUST, LIKE,
SHOCKED AT, LIKE,
STUFF THEY DON'T KNOW.
>> THE OTHERS OF YOU ARE
DOING FINE WITH NO SHOES.
BRITTANI IS THE CLOSEST
TO HAVING A WALK
THAT WOULD BE HIGH FASHION.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT YOU IS
YOU DIDN'T PUT YOUR HANDS
ON YOUR HIP ONCE.
>> ANDRÉ SAID THAT
HE REALLY LOVED MY WALK,
AND ALEXANDRIA WAS THERE
WATCHING, AND I JUST FELT
THE HATE COMING FROM HER EYES,
AND I'M LIKE... (laughs evilly)
BITCH, YOU'RE GOING DOWN!
>> THANK YOU. LET'S GO.
GET DRESSED.
WE GOT SOMEPLACE ELSE TO GO.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THAT WAS COOL.
>> I WONDER WHAT
WE'RE DOING NEXT.
>> ANOTHER GO-SEE?
>> WE FIGURE WE'RE GOING
TO ANOTHER GO-SEE,
AND WE'RE ALL JUST LIKE,
PLEASE LET US GO TO SLEEP,
DAMN IT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WELL, HI. OH, MY GOODNESS!
>> OOH!
>> YES, THEY'RE SHEER.
>> I CAN SEE.
>> WE COME TO THIS ROOFTOP
THAT OVERLOOKS MOROCCO,
AND ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY
IS THERE WITH A CUP OF TEA.
>> I'M GONNA POUR YOU MINT TEA,
WHICH IS
TYPICAL MOROCCAN HOSPITALITY.
IT IS SO WONDERFUL
THAT THIS OPPORTUNITY
HAS TAKEN YOU THIS FAR.
NO MATTER
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH,
NO MATTER HOW BAD A WEEK
YOU HAD, BRITTANI, YOU SURVIVED.
SO EACH ONE OF YOU TELL ME--
HOW DO YOU FEEL, ALEXANDRIA,
AT THIS POINT
IN THE COMPETITION?
>> I FEEL VERY, VERY UNIQUE.
>> I FEEL LIKE THERE SHOULD BE
MAYBE ONE DIFFERENT PERSON
IN THE TOP FIVE.
ALEXANDRIA--I STILL SEE HER
PUTTING ON THIS FAKE SMILE
IN FRONT OF EVERYBODY,
BE, "OH, I'M SO EXCITED!"
YOU KNOW, GRANTED, YES,
I STILL HAVE
A SLIGHT ANGER PROBLEM, TOO,
BUT, LIKE, I SEE
RIGHT THROUGH IT,
AND IT'S OBNOXIOUS.
>> I'M TAKING IT ALL IN
AS A GREAT EXPERIENCE...
>> YES.
>> AND IT'S MY FIRST COUNTRY.
>> THIS IS A BIGMOMENT
FOR YOU GUYS. THIS IS BIG.
>> YES, IT IS,
AND I'M VERY, VERY EXCITED,
SO...
HAVING THAT LITTLE TIME
TO ACTUALLY TALK TO MR. TALLEY
AND GIVE HIM A LITTLE PIECE
OF US IS AMAZING.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
GET TO DO THAT.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHY WE PICKED
THE ROOFTOP
OF THIS DOUKKALA.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHY
WE PICKED THIS ONE?
>> WHY?
>> WHY? 'CAUSE IT'S YOUR HOME.
>> (screaming)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> ENJOY YOUR BEAUTIFUL HOME.
>> WHOO!
>> ♪ HOUSE-Y, HOUSE-Y, HOUSE ♪
>> NO FIGHTING.
>> WE RUN DOWNSTAIRS
AND SEE WHERE WE'RE STAYING.
>> WHOA!
OH, MY GOODNESS!
>> AND OUR ROOMS ARE AMAZING.
>> AAH! (laughs)
>> LOOK AT THIS.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> THIS IS SO BADASS.
>> I KNOW, RIGHT?
LOOK AT ALL OF THESE.
>> WOW!
>> LOOK AT THAT!
LOOK AT OUR BATHROOM!
LITERALLY, I WAS ABOUT TO HAVE
A PANIC ATTACK.
>> OHH!
>> I CANNOT WAIT TO TAKE A BATH.
IT'S SO NOT AMERICA.
>> OH, YEAH!
>> AAH!
>> HOLY CRAP.
>> WAIT.
>> WE HAVE AN OUTDOOR SHOWER.
>> I KNOW, RIGHT?
>> THIS IS AMAZING.
LIKE, EVERYTHING'S
STILL SO SURREAL,
AND I'M JUST SO HAPPY.
>> ARE THREE OF US
SLEEPING TOGETHER?
>> I GUESS SO.
>> YOU KNOW, I SEE--
I SEE THIS BIG BED,
AND I'M LIKE, THAT'S MEANT
FOR A COUPLE PEOPLE,
SO I INSTANTLY TURN AROUND.
I'M LIKE, I'M JUST GONNA
SET MY THINGS HERE.
>> I DON'T DO WELL
WITH SLEEPING WITH OTHERS.
>> WELL, HAVE FUN. (laughs)
>> I HAVE TO SHARE A BED
WITH (bleep) BRITTANI AND KASIA,
AND I'M NOT COOL WITH THAT.
I DON'T (bleep) SHARE A BED.
THIS KIND OF PISSES ME OFF
A LITTLE BIT.
>> NO, IT'S SO COOL.
>> MOLLY WAS THE FIRST ONE
WHO WALKED INTO
WHERE WE WERE STAYING,
SO SHE HAD, LIKE, FIRST DIBS
AND DIDN'T TAKE IT,
SO YOU SNOOZE, YOU LOSE, BUDDY,
AND YOU'RE SNOOZING
IN THE BIG ROOM
WITH TWO OTHER GIRLS.
>> I CAN'T EVEN, LIKE,
SLEEP WITH MY BOYFRIEND
HALF THE TIME. (bleep).
>> MOLLY NEEDS ANGER MANAGEMENT.
SHE JUST COMPLAINS A LOT.
>> I'M NOT REALLY COOL
WITH THIS BED.
>> LIKE, I'M PRETTY SURE
SHE'S LIKE, "I HATE MY LIFE."
OH, REALLY?
SHE KINDA LETS HER ANGER
GET THE BEST OF HER,
AND SHE WILL GO HOME FOR IT,
SO FINGERS CROSSED. (chuckles)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> MOLLY IS, LIKE,
"I CAN SEE IT FROM HERE."
>> I'M NOT MOVING.
>> "YOU'VE MADE IT THIS FAR
BUT YOU'RE NOT
OVER THE HUMP YET."
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> CAMELS!
>> WHOO! CAMELS!
>> CAMELS. YES!
>> "HUMP"--HELLO, CAMELS.
UM, THE J's TOLD US EARLIER
TO TAKE IN ALL THE INSPIRATION,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE GONNA CHANNEL
THAT INTO A PHOTO SHOOT.
I HAVE TO, LIKE,
KILL THAT SHOOT.
LIKE, IT'S, LIKE, DO-OR-DIE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (bleating)
>> SO WE ARRIVE
IN THE MARRAKECH DESERT,
WHICH IS BEAUTIFUL.
IT SMELLS LIKE ANIMALS AND HAY,
AND I'M JUST LIKE... (sighs)
HOME SWEET HOME.
>> GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> WELL, I GUESS
IT'S NO SURPRISE TO YOU GUYS
TO SEE A CAMEL OUT
IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE MOROCCAN DESERT, RIGHT?
>> NO.
>> BUT THIS IS THE LOCATION
FOR YOUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT
HERE IN MOROCCO,
ON TOP OF A CAMEL.
>> WHOO!
>> AND LET ME TELL YOU,
IT IS NOT AS EASY AS IT LOOKS.
WATCH AS I TRY AND GET DOWN.
>> (grunts)
>> SEE? GRUMPY. A LITTLE GRUMPY.
OH.
>> (laughs)
>> AW.
>> THERE YOU GO.
NOW CAMELS ARE NOT
THE FRIENDLIEST OF CREATURES,
BUT TODAY I'M LOOKING TO SEE
WHICH ONE OF YOU IS
ENGINEERED TO BE A TOP MODEL,
AND MODEL THROUGH THE MISHAPS
AND ROCK YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
WITH GRUMPY MAMA OVER HERE.
>> WHOO-HOO!
>> WE HAVE FLOWN OUT
A WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
ALL THE WAY
FROM LONDON, ENGLAND.
HE HAS SHOT HERE MANY TIMES.
AND HE'S ALSO SHOT FOR MAGAZINES
LIKE "ELLE," FRENCH "GLAMOUR,"
AND ITALIAN "VOGUE"--
MR. MICHAEL WOOLLEY.
>> HELLO, GIRLS.
I'M SO EXCITED
TO BE SHOOTING YOU
IN THIS AMAZING PLACE,
AND YOU WILL BE STYLED
IN A CRAZY MIX
OF BERBER TRADITIONAL COSTUME...
>> (mouths words)
>> AND EUROPEAN SOPHISTICATION.
SO I WANT THE HORIZON
IN YOUR EYES
AND SHOW ME WHO YOU ARE.
>> I MEAN, JUST LOOK AROUND YOU.
I MEAN, THE INSPIRATION
IS RIGHT HERE.
SO, UM, LET'S GET YOU GUYS
OFF INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP
AND LET'S ROCK THIS SHOOT OUT.
>> YEAH.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> BUT IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
GORGEOUS.
>> I'M REALLY EXCITED.
I'M SO READY TO RIDE THIS CAMEL.
I WANNA, LIKE, RIDE IT
ALL ACROSS THE DESERT AND BACK.
>> (grunts)
>> YOU GOT IT, RIGHT?
>> OH, YEAH.
I'M A PROFESSIONAL CAMEL RIDER.
>> OKAY, WE CAN GO UP.
>> IT WAS A LOT HARDER
THAN I EXPECTED
TO POSE ON A CAMEL,
'CAUSE I KIND OF HAD TO, LIKE,
HOLD MY THIGHS TOGETHER
REALLY TIGHT
TO MAKE SURE I DIDN'T FALL OFF.
>> HEY, BRITTANI,
I KNOW YOU'RE JUST
GETTING THE FEEL OF IT,
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE, LIKE,
CLAMPING ONTO THE CAMEL
FOR DEAR LIFE WITH YOUR LEGS.
>> OKAY.
>> JUST KICK THAT OUT FOR ME
AND THEN JUST DROP YOUR HAND.
WORKING WITH THE ELEMENTS.
THAT'S IT. HERE YOU GO.
>> YES, BEAUTIFUL.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> I LOVE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
NOW, BRITTANI, IN TERMS
OF YOUR--YOUR BODY LANGUAGE.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN HAVING
CONTORTION LESSONS?
>> UH-OH.
>> ONCE I DECIDED
TO STAND ON IT, TO SEE
WHAT THEY THOUGHT OF THAT,
LIKE, IT WAS
REALLY, REALLY DIFFICULT
'CAUSE MY THIGHS WERE SHAKING
THE WHOLE TIME.
HEY NOW, CAMEL.
COOPERATE WITH ME HERE.
BUT I DID THE BEST I COULD.
I HOPE I GOT A GOOD SHOT.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> BRITTANI HAS GOT
HER MOJO BACK.
THERE YOU GO.
I BELIEVE THE JOURNEY.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
HER CONFIDENCE IS BACK.
>> OKAY.
>> THANKS, BRITTANI.
>> (gasps)
I CAN'T STAND.
(groans)
>> IT'S REALLY, REALLY HOT.
OOH!
AND I'VE ALWAYS NEEDED TO
KINDA DEAL WITH MY ANGER
AND MY IMPATIENCE AND STUFF,
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING I WANT,
SO I HAVE TO PRETEND
NOT TO BE A BITCH
LIKE I REALLY AM,
SO I WON'T GO HOME.
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW YOUR NAME.
>> MOLLY.
>> MOLLY. OKAY.
YOU LOOK LIKE A MOLLY.
>> YEAH?
>> YES.
>> (forced laugh)
AWESOME.
>> HE'S SHOOTING
THE WHOLE TIME YOU'RE MOUNTING,
SO YOU'RE POSING THE WHOLE WAY.
>> IT CAN DEFINITELY
BE HARD BEING ON A CAMEL.
YOU NOT ONLY HAVE TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE FACT THAT YOU NEED
TO GET A GOOD PICTURE,
BUT YOU CAN'T ANGER THE CAMEL
'CAUSE THEY'RE CRANKY.
>> HOLD ON, BUT YOU'RE MODELING.
YES. YES. THERE YOU GO. GOOD.
>> YOU GOT IT.
THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
>> MOLLY NAILED THIS SHOOT
FROM THE GET-GO.
THAT WAS REALLY SEXY,
THE WAY YOU LEANED BACK
AND CREATED THAT SHAPE.
IT WAS VERY CHANEL.
>> YEAH.
>> OKAY, SO WE CAN WRAP HER.
NO, I'M JUST KIDDING.
MOLLY JUST WENT WITH
WHICHEVER WAY THE CAMEL DID,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY,
SHE BROUGHT TENSION TO THE SHOT.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
THAT'S COOL.
>> YEAH, I THINK WE'RE GOOD.
>> MOLLY'S SHOOT
KINDA SEEMED TO JUST FALL
ACCIDENTALLY INTO PLACE,
LIKE, WHENEVER THE CAMEL GOT UP,
SHE JUST SO HAPPENED
TO LEAN BACK AND JERK FORWARD
LIKE SHE DID.
>> (chuckles)
>> I MEAN, ANYBODY
COULD HAVE DONE THAT.
>> THAT WAS AMAZING.
SOME PEOPLE SAY IT'S LUCK.
SOME PEOPLE SAY
IT'S BEING PREPARED.
>> I'D LIKE TO SAY
IT'S BEING PREPARED. (chuckles)
EXCUSE ME. THANK YOU.
>> KASIA, YOU GOOD?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> YOU EXCITED?
>> YES.
MY STRATEGY FOR THE SHOOT IS
JUST TO BRING A LOT OF EMOTION
IN THE FACE, BUT ALSO HAVE
REALLY GREAT BODY SHAPES,
WHICH IS NOT GONNA BE
THE EASIEST THING
ON TOP OF A CAMEL.
>> (grunts)
(camera shutter clicks)
>> QUIETER.
I'M SURE YOU CAN FIND
SOMETHING UNDERSTATED.
NOW WE'RE GETTING
A BIT TOO POSE-Y
AND CATALOG-ISH.
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE SHE'S STUCK.
STRETCH, STRETCH,
LIKE, BREATHE LIFE INTO IT.
OH, NOW INHALE LIKE...
(inhales deeply)
MM.
>> THAT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE FALLING OFF THE CAMEL.
NO.
FOR A PHOTOGRAPHER,
HE NEEDS TO FEEL
THAT HE'S IN CONTROL.
I FELT OUT OF CONTROL
WITH KASIA.
AND FRANKLY,
IT WAS PAINFUL SHOOTING HER.
>> OKAY, WE CAN BRING HER DOWN.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I'M JUST FRUSTRATED.
>> WHY ARE YOU FRUSTRATED?
>> (crying) LIKE,
WHEN IT'S NOT WORKING,
I THINK I GET, LIKE,
SELF-CONSCIOUS.
>> SELF-CONSCIOUS OF WHAT?
>> LIKE, HOW MY BODY'S LOOKING.
I DON'T KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY, I'M HERE
BECAUSE I WANT TO DO
HIGH FASHION. (sniffles)
BUT IT'S, LIKE,
I KNOW A LOT OF IT
DOESN'T WORK FOR ME.
>> I PERSONALLY BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS A HUGE PLACE
IN THIS BUSINESS
FOR PLUS SIZE MODELS.
YOU'RE SEEING KARL LAGERFELD--
LIKE, THEY'RE--ZAC POSEN--
THEY'RE ALL BOOKING
PLUS SIZE GIRLS.
AND IN TERMS OF YOUR BODY,
IF YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT YOUR BODY LOOKS LIKE,
THAT MEANS YOU'RE NOT PRESENT
AND YOU'RE NOT ENGAGED.
>> YEAH.
>> WE'LL SEE
WHAT THE JUDGES HAVE TO SAY.
WE'LL GO THROUGH YOUR FILM.
THANKS, KASIA.
>> (sniffles)
>> I'M SO EXCITED
BECAUSE WE'RE WORKING
WITH ANIMALS AGAIN,
AND I LOVE ANIMALS.
>> (grunts)
>> HEY!
>> BY THE WAY, SHE IS
GONNA HOLD ON,
LIKE, A GALE-FORCE WIND
IS NOT GONNA ALLOW YOU
TO PULL HER OFF THE SET.
>> OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
>> SO PUSH.
>> OKAY.
>> (grunts)
>> I WOULD LIKE
TO REALLY HIT THIS
OUT OF THE PARK, SO...
>> OKAY.
WELL, I THINK "HIT IT
OUT OF THE PARK"
IS THE WRONG ALLUSION.
IT'S NOT BASEBALL.
>> NO.
>> WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE DESERT.
>> I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOODNESS.
I JUST PROBABLY SAID
THE MOST STUPID THING TO A BRIT.
THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT BASEBALL IS.
I SHOULD'VE MADE, LIKE,
A CRICKET REFERENCE
OR A POLO REFERENCE.
I REALLY FEEL
THAT I'M CONNECTED TO THIS,
AND I WANT TO BE A PART OF THIS.
>> 'CAUSE UNFORTUNATELY,
BEING A MODEL
IS SOMETHING MORE THAN THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU HAVE TO FEEL IT
IN YOUR HEART AND YOUR SOUL.
>> OKAY.
>> I'M LIKE,
NOW HE THINKS I'M STUPID.
ARE--ARE YOU KIDDING ME, BRO?
>> MODEL THROUGH IT.
>> OOH.
YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
WAY TOO MUCH.
>> GO WITH IT.
>> OOH!
>> LOOK AT ME.
>> WITHOUT RAISING YOUR EYEBROW.
(scoffs)
SO ALEXANDRIA WAS
A HUGE STRUGGLE.
ALEXANDRIA JUST WILL NOT LET GO.
SHE'S SO CONTROLLED.
IT'S JUST LOOKS SO CONTRIVED.
IT'S KILLING ME.
>> TURN YOUR SHOULDER
AWAY FROM ME,
ALMOST A BACK SHOT AND THEN--
THAT'S TOO MUCH BACK.
AND THEN--OKAY.
>> AND THE THING IS,
SHE CAN BE SO MUCH BETTER
THAT THAT.
YOU HAVE TO LET GO OF THE REINS,
SO TO SPEAK,
AND TRULY COME ALIVE.
I DON'T KNOW.
THERE'S JUST
AN AWKWARDNESS HERE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE, HOLDING--LIKE HOLDING
A THING LIKE THIS
AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST--
I WANT SOMETHING FRESH AND NEW.
>> YEAH.
>> LIKE, WHAT DO YOU--
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU CAN DO
TO BREAK THAT, TO LET GO?
>> DIRECT MYSELF.
>> THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> JUST DO MY THING.
>> I THINK THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
I THINK YOU'RE
OVERDIRECTING YOURSELF.
>> OKAY. OKAY.
>> YOU'RE THINKING TOO MUCH
ABOUT IT.
>> OKAY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I WAS DOING.
I WAS FEELING THE MOMENT.
JUST (bleep) DUMB.
>> GO FOR IT.
IF YOU WANT TO STAND UP,
STAND UP.
>> I SAW PART OF ALEXANDRIA'S,
AND SHE, LIKE, DOING THE...
SAME THING SHE ALWAYS DOES.
>> YOU'RE NOT LOOKING AT ME.
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR WATER.
YOU'RE LOST.
>> I MEAN, HONESTLY,
SHE DOESN'T LOOK AS MODEL-Y
AS THE REST OF US DO.
I FEEL LIKE
SHE'S NOT GONNA MAKE IT
TO THE VERY END.
>> I THINK WE GOT IT.
THANK YOU.
>> DO YOU LIKE THAT?
I WANNA PROVE TO THE PEOPLE
WHO SAID I'M UNMEMORABLE...
(whispers) WRONG.
(normal voice) I BROUGHT
MY OWN ENERGY
AND REALLY TRIED TO MAKE IT
A UNIQUE SHOOT.
>> OKAY, HANNAH, GO FOR IT.
>> THIS ISN'T LIKE
A BUCKING BRONCO BACK HOME.
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
>> GOING UP.
THAT'S IT.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN RIDING BULLS
IN YOUR SPARE TIME?
>> MAYBE A COUPLE ELECTRIC ONES.
>> 'CAUSE YOU'RE GIVING ME
BRONCO WILD, LIKE...
BUT IT WORKS.
>> CAN WE DO THAT AGAIN?
>> GOOD, HANNAH.
I LOVE THE TENSION IN YOUR BODY.
THIS IS PERFECT.
IT'S LONG, IT'S ELEGANT.
>> YEAH, GOOD. WONDERFUL.
EVERY TIME THAT CAMEL
GOT UP IN THE AIR,
IT'S LIKE SHE WAS ON A LIFT.
SHE GAVE ME THE FEELING
THAT I WANTED
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE SHOOT
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY WERE ALONE
IN THIS GREAT, BIG DESERT.
IT WAS FULL OF ATMOSPHERE.
BRAVO, GIRL.
THIS IS TO FINISH.
YOU'RE SAILING OFF
INTO THE SUNSET.
THAT'S IT! WE'VE GOT THAT.
>> I KNOW I GOT GOOD FEEDBACK.
I THINK I GOT A GOOD PHOTO.
AS FAR AS MY PERSONALITY GOES,
I ACTUALLY STARTED DOING
SOMETHING THAT WAS MISSING
BEFORE.
>> THAT--
WELL, THAT'S A WRAP, EVERYONE.
HANNAH, THAT WAS EXCELLENT.
GOOD JOB.
>> YAY! THANK YOU.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OH. HEY.
OH!
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY FOUR WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPE OF BECOMING"...
>> AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (singsongy) OUR FIRST
MOROCCAN PANEL!
>> OH, MY.
>> WAIT. SO WHAT--
WHO IS WORRIED FOR TOMORROW?
>> I'M WORRIED.
I'M ALWAYS WORRIED FOR PANEL.
>> YEAH.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
I'M KIND OF NERVOUS
TO MAYBE BE IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
I JUST GOT HERE,
AND I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE YET.
SO I JUST HOPE
FOR A GREAT SHOT.
I DON'T KNOW.
IT WAS JUST REALLY...
>> FRUSTRATING?
>> YEAH.
>> THE TOP FIVE IS GONNA
SLOWLY DWINDLE DOWN TO ONE,
AND I'M REALLY SAD
TO SEE EVERYBODY GO,
BUT IT HAS TO HAPPEN,
BECAUSE SOMEBODY
HAS TO BE ON TOP.
(ding)
>> I GUESS I...
MADE THE PHOTOGRAPHER
LOSE HIS TEMPER.
>> OOH.
>> REALLY?
>> HE WAS LIKE,
OKAY, THIS IS NOT WORKING.
AND I'M LIKE, I'M TRYING.
>> I MEAN, LEX SAID
SHE DIDN'T DO TOO GREAT
BUT SHE FEELS OKAY ABOUT IT,
SO IF SHE'S SAYING SHE DIDN'T
DO TOO GREAT, THEN THAT MUST
MEAN SHE REALLY SUCKED,
'CAUSE USUALLY, SHE'S LIKE,
"I DID FANTASTIC.
I DID AWESOME."
>> I'M IN THE DESERT,
I'M ON A CAMEL, I'M--I'M LOST.
I'M VERY NERVOUS
AND I'M JUST
REALLY DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO BE
THE FIRST ONE TO GO HOME.
I WORKED THROUGH IT.
I WORKED IT OUT IN THE END,
I HOPE TO GOD.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I SMELL LIKE A CAMEL.
>> NO, YOU DO NOT.
>> (imitates European accent)
OH, DARLING, I HAVEN'T BATHED
SINCE I GOT OFF THAT PLANE,
DARLING.
>> AND APPARENTLY,
YOU CAME THROUGH LONDON
AND ALL KINDS OF PLACES.
>> (normal voice) YES,
AND FRANCA--SHE HELPED,
BABYSAT ME WHILE I WAS LOST.
>> OH, YOU WERE
ON THE SAME PLANE?
>> SHE HAS--SHE HAS
A BEAUTIFUL 2-FINGERED TYPING
LIKE I DO, VERY FAST.
>> I'M THE SAME WAY, YEAH.
>> SHE'S LIKE THIS...
>> HI, EVERYBODY.
>> HELLO.
>> WE'RE IN MOROCCO,
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE WORLD.
HOW AMAZING IS THIS,
YOU GUYS HAVE GOTTEN THIS FAR?
AS YOU KNOW, A LOT OF MODELS
COME HERE TO DO PHOTO SHOOTS.
AND THIS WAS ONE
OF MY FAVORITE LOCATIONS
WHEN I WAS A MODEL.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> SO YOU GUYS ARE
SUPER-DUPER LUCKY.
YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH IMG MODELS, ONE OF THE TOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS,
A SPREAD IN "VOGUE ITALIA,"
A COVER OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE"
AND A SPREAD,
AND YOU'LL BE FEATURED
ON vogue.it, THEIR WEB SITE.
OUR JUDGES--
MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY, ONE OF
THE MOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN ALL OF THE FASHION WORLD,
AND FRANCA SOZZANI.
SHE IS THE EDITOR IN CHIEF
OF "VOGUE ITALIA,"
AND SHE HAS YOUR FUTURES
IN HER HANDS.
ARE WE READY TO START?
>> YES.
>> SO OUR LADIES HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT
IN THE DESERT
WITH CAMELS.
BRITTANI, YOU'RE FIRST.
HOW WAS IT LIKE
SHOOTING WITH A CAMEL?
>> IT WAS SO MUCH FUN.
I LOVED IT.
>> WELL, HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS
I LOVE ABOUT IT?
IT'S VERY ANDROGYNOUS.
YOU ALMOST COULD BE A BOY
OR A MAN IN THIS SHOT,
YET IT'S VERY BEAUTIFUL,
AND THIS SORT OF
"LAWRENCE OF ARABIA" FEEL TO IT.
>> FOR ME,
SHE'S NOT NATURAL ENOUGH.
SHE'S BEAUTIFUL,
BUT SHE'S VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
AROUND HER.
>> FOR ME, IT'S A NARRATIVE
RIGHT OUT OF THE '60s "VOGUE,"
AND I JUST THINK THAT YOU LOOK
AS IF YOU'RE ON A CARAVAN,
AND YOU'RE SUDDENLY--
YOU'VE SEEN THE OASIS
THAT'S NOT REALLY THERE.
I THINK IT'S VERY DRAMATIC
AND I FIND IT VERY HIGH FASHION.
>> I LOVE A NARRATIVE.
I LOVE THIS PICTURE.
I THINK YOU ARE TAKING A CHANCE,
YOU'RE TAKING A RISK,
AND YOU HAVE THAT IN YOU.
YOU JUST HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU DON'T HURT YOURSELF
BECAUSE YOU JUST WILL GO.
THIS IS LIKE AN AD CAMPAIGN.
ALL RIGHT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, BRITTANI.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHTY. WHO'S NEXT?
ALEXANDRIA.
>> HELLO.
>> LOOKING SO SWEET
WITH YOUR HAIR BACK TODAY.
>> YES.
>> LOOKING MUCH MORE MODEL-Y.
>> (imitates surfer) AS OPPOSED
TO "DUDE, YOU KNOW, LIKE,
I HEARD ABOUT
THIS MODELING THING.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?"
LIKE I TOTALLY...
(normal voice) I DON'T KNOW WHAT
MY ACCENT'S DOING RIGHT NOW.
BUT ANYWAY, YOU DON'T WANT
TO COME IN WITH THE CLIENT
FEELING ONE SPECIFIC THING.
(imitates surfer) LET'S
SEE YOUR BEST SHOT
WITH THE CAMEL.
>> I LOVE YOUR UPPER BODY.
I WISH YOUR LEGS WERE
A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
JUST THAT GAP BETWEEN,
THAT SORT OF DISTANCE,
FOR ME, JUST LOOKS, UH, WEIRD.
>> ALL YOU GIRLS HAVE TO WORK
ON RELAXING THE MOUTH,
THE TENSION.
THIS WOULD BE A PERFECT PICTURE
FOR ME, BUT WHEN I LOOK
AT YOUR FACE, IT LOOKS ANGRY.
INDIGESTION? CONSTIPATION?
>> OH.
>> THE ONLY THING THAT IS
FOR ME, IS IT BECOMES
A LITTLE BIT STIFF
IS THE--THE ARM.
BUT, UM, I LIKE THIS PICTURE.
I REALLY DO.
>> (normal voice) IN YOUR FILM,
I THINK YOU STRUGGLED A BIT.
IT FELT A LITTLE INCONSISTENT.
THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID
THAT HE FELT YOU WERE
TALKING BACK
AND KIND OF INSTRUCTING HIM
OR...
>> I THINK THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
I THINK YOU'RE
OVERDIRECTING YOURSELF.
>> OKAY. OKAY.
>> YOU'RE THINKING TOO MUCH
ABOUT IT.
>> OKAY.
I HADN'T SAID ANYTHING.
>> PART OF THESE THINGS IS
THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU...
IT'S HOW YOU ARE PERCEIVED.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND QUITE OFTEN YOU HAVE BEEN
POTENTIALLY MISREAD...
>> YES.
>> BECAUSE YOU DON'T FEEL THAT,
YOU KNOW, IT'S FAIR,
WHETHER IT'S FROM THE GIRLS
OR WHETHER IT'S FROM
PEOPLE IN PREVIOUS PHOTO SHOOTS,
AND THAT'S ONE OF THESE THINGS
IN THIS--SORTS OF SITUATIONS,
WHERE YOU HAVE TO BE VERY AWARE.
>> THE PHOTOGRAPHER HAS A LOT
OF POWER ON THE PHOTO SHOOT,
SO IF HE'S FEELING LIKE
YOU'RE GIVING HIM
ANY ATTITUDE OR ANYTHING,
HE MIGHT EVEN JUST
HAND WHATEVER TO THE MAGAZINE,
AND THEN WHAT RUNS IS
EITHER NOTHING OR SOMETHING
THAT DOESN'T LOOK GREAT,
AND VERY RARELY DO THEY SAY
"THIS IS BAD PHOTOGRAPHY."
THEY SAY THE MODEL
LOOKS LIKE CRAP.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, UP NEXT IS KASIA.
KASIA, HOW WERE YOU
WITH THE CAMEL?
>> GOOD. UM, I MEAN,
I LOVE THE CAMELS.
IT WAS FUN.
I HAD TROUBLE POSING, I GUESS,
YOU KNOW,
MAKING MY BODY LOOK GOOD.
>> HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I LIKE IT.
I WOULD L-LOVE TO SEE A LIT--
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE LIGHT
AND A SOFTER LOOK IN YOUR EYES.
YOU SAID YOU HAD PROBLEMS
MAKING YOUR BODY LOOK GOOD.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I MEAN, I GUESS
WHAT I WAS TRYING
DIDN'T SEEM TO BE WORKING.
AND, LIKE, WE TRIED
A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
>> YOU SEEMED SELF-CONSCIOUS
WHEN I WAS GOING
THROUGH YOUR FILM.
YOUR MOUTH WAS TIGHT
IN EVERY SHOT, YOU KNOW,
I JUST FELT TENSION.
>> IT IS NOT STRONG ENOUGH.
IT'S LIKE A LACK OF ENERGY
TO GIVE TO THE PHOTOGRAPHER.
>> I AGREE WITH FRANCA.
I FEEL THERE'S A LACK OF ENERGY
IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
I FIND IT VERY PROBLEMATIC.
I AM NOT FEELING
THE NOMADIC NARRATIVE
OF GOING OFF INTO
THE ROMANTIC DESERT HERE.
>> PHOTOGRAPHERS ALWAYS MARK,
LIKE, WHAT THEY LIKE,
AND, UM, HE ONLY CHOSE ONE,
AND I FEEL THAT YOU'RE BETTER
THAN JUST BEING ABLE TO HAVE
ONE USABLE SHOT.
YOUR--YOUR HEAD IS
CONTROLLING YOUR BODY
IN THE WRONG WAY,
AND YOU REALLY NEED
TO PUSH THAT CRITIC ASIDE,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE EXPERIENCE,
AND IT'S TIME FOR YOU
TO RISE TO THAT AND SAY,
"I-I'VE DONE THIS, AND I CAN
DO BETTER THAN YOU GUYS."
OKAY. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
UP NEXT IS MOLLY.
>> HELLO.
>> ARE YOU READY TO SEE
YOUR BEST SHOT?
>> YES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> GREAT SHOT.
>> THE WAY THAT SHE IS
AT THE BODY, I THINK
IT'S REALLY, REALLY NICE.
IT'S VERY NATURAL,
SO I THINK IT'S, UH,
IT'S VERY GOOD.
>> WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT PHOTOGRAPHS IN MAGAZINES,
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS,
DO YOU SEE THE MESSAGE
OF THE CLOTHES?
AND HERE, I SEE THE MESSAGE
OF THE HIGH FASHION PRINCESS
ON HER OWN CARAVAN,
AND IT IS AN AMAZING PHOTOGRAPH.
IT'S ANCHORED,
BUT IT'S STILL FLY-AWAY.
I LOVE IT.
>> YOU KIND OF FEEL
THE MODEL IN THE MOMENT
AS OPPOSED TO HER GOING
"I AM MODELING."
>> YES.
>> BUT YOU'RE VERY AWARE,
BECAUSE A MODEL IS ALWAYS AWARE.
THAT'S WHY THEY MAKE
AWFUL ACTRESSES
A LOT OF THE TIMES
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO AWARE,
EVEN WHEN THEY'RE PRETENDING
THAT THEY'RE NOT.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
IS HANNAH.
>> HOW DOES IT FEEL
ON THE CAMEL?
>> UH, IT WAS KIND OF LIKE
AN ELECTRIC BULL--
THE SAME, LIKE,
MOTIONS AND STUFF.
>> HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> WHAT I REALLY LOVE
ABOUT THIS PICTURE IS
THAT IT'S VERY DIFFERENT
FROM ANY OF THE OTHER GIRLS'.
AND IT'S A--IT'S A VERY SORT OF
CURRENT-LOOKING PICTURE FOR ME.
>> HANNAH, I THINK IT'S
A WONDERFUL PHOTOGRAPH OF YOU.
I LOVE THE HAIR, THE SCARF.
THE ONLY WEAKNESS IS
THE WAY YOU HAVE YOUR HAND HERE,
BUT IT DOESN'T DISTRACT
FROM THE GREAT ROMANTIC STORY,
AND IT IS VERY EDGY,
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
I SEE CLOTHES.
>> I AGREE.
IT'S A REALLY GOOD PICTURE.
IT'S NATURAL. IT'S VERY GOOD.
UM, I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
THE EXPRESSION ON THE FACE,
HONESTLY. NOT STRONG ENOUGH.
>> NOT STRONG.
>> WELL, HANNAH,
I LOOKED THROUGH ALL YOUR FILM,
AND YOU WERE AMAZING.
YOU WERE CREATING
THAT WONDERFUL MOMENTUM
THAT MADE ME THINK
THAT THE PICTURE WAS DOING
SOMETHING TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> ALL RIGHTY.
NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE THE FIRST GIRL
THAT IS GOING HOME FROM MOROCCO.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME
TO DELIBERATE.
>> MM-HMM.
>> OUR VERY FIRST
MOROCCAN DELIBERATION.
WHAT DO WE THINK
ABOUT BRITTANI?
>> I THINK THIS IS
A GREAT SHOT OF BRITTANI.
IT'S DIFFERENT.
IT'S UNUSUAL FOR A GIRL
TO BE STANDING ON A CAMEL.
SHE TOOK A RISK.
>> I LIKE IT A LOT,
AND I THINK IT'S DRAMATIC,
AND SHE SOLD ME.
>> SHE IS PRETTY,
BUT THIS PICTURE IS BEING MADE
BY THE PHOTOGRAPHER
AND BY THE STYLIST,
BUT NOT BY HER FACE
AND NOT BY HER BODY.
>> I LIKE THE OVER-THE-TOPNESS
OF IT.
IS IT AMAZING, WHERE I'M LIKE,
"OH, GOD, I MUST HAVE THIS
IN MY SALON"?
>> NO.
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> THIS IS A FLAT PICTURE
FOR ME.
ALEXANDRIA JUST WENT FLAT,
AND I THINK THAT
SHE LOOKS ANGRY.
>> I THINK IT'S WEIRD,
IT'S UNUSUAL,
IT'S OUT OF PLACE.
TO HEAR THAT SHE'S BEEN
HAVING PROBLEMS ON SET AGAIN
SEEMS TO BE A REOCCURRING THEME.
AND EVEN WHEN SHE PRETENDS,
EVEN THOUGH SHE CAN
BE QUITE NICE AND SHE CAN
BE VERY PLEASANT TO YOU,
IT FEELS FAKE.
>> SHE LOOKS LIKE A LITTLE GIRL,
AND SHE WANTS IT NOW,YOU KNOW.
>> SHE SHOULD HAVE JUMPED OFF.
>> (laughs)
>> AND BROKEN HER ANKLE.
>> WOULDN'T BE IN THE SHOT.
>> KASIA.
>> SHE LOOKS LIKE ONE OF THOSE
TRYING TO BE
A BYZANTINE PRINCESS BUT IS--
SHE'S COMING OFF TO ME
LIKE A MAD TOURIST.
>> I THINK IT'S A GREAT PICTURE.
SHE LOOKS AS A TOURIST
BECAUSE HER FACE,
THE WAY THAT SHE HAS...
>> WOULD YOU PUT THAT PHOTOGRAPH
IN THE MAGAZINE
IF THAT STORY WAS APPROPRIATE?
>> NOT THAT PHOTOGRAPH.
NO, OF COURSE.
>> NO.
>> WHAT ABOUT HER AS A MODEL?
>> NO, I DON'T SEE...
(speaks indistinctly)
>> I MEAN, LOOK,
I ACTUALLY THINK THIS PICTURE
IS GREAT.
I THINK YOU SELECTED
A GREAT SHOT,
BUT WE HEAR FROM HER
AS WELL AS YOURSELF
THAT THERE WEREN'T
THAT MANY GREAT SHOTS OF HER.
>> YEAH. MOLLY.
>> IN THIS PICTURE,
SHE LOOKS VERY ELEGANT.
SHE HAS A REAL, UH,
MODEL ATTITUDE.
THIS COULD BE A PICTURE
FOR "VOGUE."
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE ATTITUDE
'CAUSE SHE CERTAINLY
SEEMS TO HAVE IT.
>> THIS IS A DRAMATIC PICTURE,
AND IT'S A STORY.
IT'S A NARRATIVE.
AND FASHION HAS TO BE
A NARRATIVE.
SHE'S ON A VOYAGE.
SHE'S ON AN INTERNATIONAL
NOMADIC VOYAGE.
>> I AGREE.
HANNAH.
>> THIS IS A GREAT SHOT
OF HANNAH, INTERESTING SHOT.
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT
FROM ANY OF THE OTHER GIRLS,
BUT I DON'T REALLY THINK
THAT SHE ACTUALLY UNDERSTANDS
THE NARRATIVE.
>> EVEN SOME OF THE GREAT MODELS
SOMETIMES DON'T THINK,
BUT THEY STILL MAKE
FABULOUS PHOTOS.
>> WHAT IS A LITTLE BIT
THE LACK OF, UH, THIS GIRL...
>> ENERGY. ENERGY.
>> IS THE ENERGY.
TO BE A MODEL,
EVEN IF YOU DON'T THINK,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN ATTITUDE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> BUT SHE LOOKS BEAUTIFUL.
HAVE WE REACHED A DECISION?
>> WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> FIVE BEAUTIFUL LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE FOUR PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT ARE
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GONNA CALL
IS BEST PICTURE.
MOLLY.
I THINK YOU KINDA KNEW IT.
>> I HAD A FEELING.
>> YOU HAD A FEELING.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
RUNNER-UP FOR BEST PHOTO IS...
BRITTANI.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> HANNAH.
>> (exhales deeply)
>> YOU LOOK SO ADORABLE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND THIS IS REALLY GREAT.
YOU SHOULD BE PROUD OF YOURSELF.
>> THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (whispers) THANKS. THANKS.
>> WILL ALEXANDRIA AND KASIA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> TWO BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME,
AND THE GIRL I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO HER HOME HERE IN MOROCCO,
PACK YOUR BAGS, AND GO HOME.
ALEXANDRIA, YOU STAND BEFORE ME
BECAUSE YOUR PICTURES
ARE BEAUTIFUL,
FANTASTIC, STRONG,
BUT NOT AS STRONG
AS THE LADIES TO YOUR RIGHT.
YOU HAVE A TALENT,
AND IT'S SPOTTY.
AND THE JUDGES AREN'T SURE
IF THEY CAN TRUST
YOUR DEMEANOR ON SET.
AND THEN WE HAVE KASIA,
A GIRL WHOSE FILM
I LOVE EDITING...
SOMETIMES.
SOME WEEKS IT IS, "OH, MY GOSH.
WHICH ONE DO I PICK?
WHICH ONE DO I PICK?"
BUT THEN SOME WEEKS,
IT'S "OH, MY GOSH.
SHE'S IN THE TRASH.
NIGEL'S STRUGGLING.
WHAT AM I GONNA DO?"
AND THIS GIRL
WITH THIS GORGEOUS BODY
THAT STANDS
FOR A POSITIVE MESSAGE,
BUT SHE DOESN'T HAVE
THAT CONFIDENCE IN HER PHOTOS
TO BE CONSISTENT TO MATCH UP
WITH THIS GORGEOUS BODY.
SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> ALEXANDRIA.
>> (speaks inaudibly)
>> THE REASON WHY
YOUR NAME WAS CALLED IS
YOUR PICTURES ARE STRONGER
AND MORE CONSISTENT
AGAINST KASIA'S PHOTOS.
BUT YOU HAVE SOME WORK TO DO.
>> (whispers) YES, MA'AM.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
WHAT'S UP WITH THE GIRL
THAT WAS INDIE MAGAZINE,
TAKING SUCH BEAUTIFUL PHOTOS
ALREADY,
THAT GOES BACK AND FORTH?
WHAT IS THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW?
>> (scoffs) I'M
REALLY DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF.
>> WHEN YOU GET ON THAT SET,
THAT PHOTOGRAPHER
AND THAT EDITOR AND THAT STYLIST
AND EVERYBODY
THAT HAS HIRED YOU--YOU WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THEY DON'T THINK
THAT THEY EVER MADE A MISTAKE.
CONSISTENCY IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVEN BEING THE BEST.
OKAY?
>> (whispers) OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> (whispers) YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> I KNEW I'D BE
IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
BUT I DIDN'T THINK I WAS
GONNA BE THE ONE GOING HOME.
I GOT TO THE TOP FIVE, LIKE,
THAT IS A HUGE ACCOMPLISHMENT,
I KNOW,
BUT I KNOW I CAN DO BETTER,
AND THAT'S WHAT'S KILLING ME.
AND I'M NOT GIVING UP.
I HAVE A LOT OF ASPIRATIONS,
A LOT OF BIG DREAMS,
AND IT'S NOT OVER.
IT'S JUST A BUMP IN THE ROAD
FOR ME.
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.